it's cotton-picking season here on the
edge of the Fergana Valley the crop is
good this year but it's not what it used
to be and it's not because waters Pierce
here in Kyrgyzstan but because in some
parts is become out of reach because of
a disputed border the marina de Mer at
buy more ZF remembers how he used to
spend time at the foot of these
mountains with them with them with them
we used to swim in the lake there we
practically grew up there we played all
day and celebrated all the holidays the
whole village would get together to
celebrate that's how it was now they
have to pull in a boarder now the
mountains and the reservoir the villages
of Kirk Eden relied on an Uzbek East and
the plot of land around the circadian
reservoir was exchanged for another
parcel of land further away of exactly
the same size the Kyrgyz government says
its irrigated flat land which the
country lacks the swap is part of an
agreement between the two sides over a
border demarcation still not finalized
since Kyrgyzstan and Uzbekistan gained
independence after the fall of the
Soviet Union
it runs for more than 1,300 kilometers
and it started with land claimed by both
sides
this is disputed territory it's over the
sources neutral sources mostly water
sources because in that territories we
have a dams we had we have a lakes and
we have a see we have a legs and we have
a canals which is extremely important
for all these neighboring countries and
this is also disputed territories over
the energy sources the Fergana Valley is
the agricultural heartland of Central
Asia divided among Kyrgyzstan Uzbekistan
into the southwest
Tajikistan the irony is that kyrgyzstan
an upstream water rich country relies on
its neighbor for water in some parts of
the Fergana Valley the two countries are
linked by a soviet-era canal network so
the water flows first to the circadian
reservoir now on whose Becklund and then
back
to Kyrgyzstan something that baffles
dilmer ad by mirzayev castanos uh lately
the logic is lost in kyrgyzstan you
can't explain why we have water but at
the same time we don't I keep on
thinking about it it's like having a
garden but you can't go for a walk it's
nonsense kukuda now relies on another
reservoir further inland but water
remains a source of tension here with
many saying whoever controls its flow
will likely emerge as the regional power
in Central Asia heard Abdel Hamid al
jazeera kyrgyzstan